[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's up
prof i'm martin smith
this is walter fight
hi martin are you well no i'm going to
ask you how are you today i'm very well
i'm going to turn it around yeah i'm
good thank you
no no no you can't be because the bible
says there's nobody good no not one okay
sorry i am doing well
fine
what are we talking about today we're
continuing our topic
we looked at
the causes of disease last time
and we spoke about
good blood
and all of the the thoughts
out there and this time we're going to
take it to a practical level and have a
look at practical health in a time such
as this okay so let's open with a word
of prayer
our heavenly father
thank you for giving us the privilege of
these discussions
you gave us
all the knowledge through the bible so
help us to implement these things into
our lives we ask this in jesus name amen
amen
well martin
in a time of crisis
when all earthly support is cut off
how do you deal with these things
if you've made that mind shift
from disease is actually
my friend
and not my enemy
and he's telling me that there's
something that i have to take care of
now some of that can be introduced from
outside in the form of toxins or
whatever
and
so we have to look at how do we help
the disease to cope with certain issues
now one of the things that
bothers people is
that natural remedies
seem to take time
and people say you know they don't work
we want something that gives instant
relief right so they add a drug to the
problem
and actually exacerbate the problem
here's an interesting quote from the
ministry of healing
the use of natural remedies requires an
amount of care and effort
that many are not willing to give
natchez process of healing and
upbuilding is gradual
and to the impatient it seems slow
the surrender of hurtful indulgences
requires sacrifice
but in the end it will be found that
nature untrammeled
does her work wisely and well
those who persevere in obedience to her
laws will reap the reward in health of
body and health of mind
again you have the body and the mind oh
that's so important it's not
all about
your physical well-being it's about
the mind as well correct
and then
make use of the remedies that god has
provided and we've looked at them before
pure air sunshine
and the intelligent use of water
that's an interesting clue
are beneficial agents in the restoration
of health
but the use of water is considered too
laborious it is easier to employ drugs
than to use natural remedies
that's a problem with humanity right
instant fix
so we are actually admonished to educate
away from drugs
drug medication as it is generally
practiced is a curse
educate away from drugs use them less
and less and depend more upon hygienic
agencies
then nature will respond to god's
physicians pure air pure water
proper exercise a clear conscience
those who persist in the use of tea
coffee flesh meats will feel the need of
drugs
but many might recover without one grain
of medicine if they would obey the laws
of health drugs need
seldom be used
in another place it says can be
dispensed with all together yeah
now
why are flesh meats always on the list
flesh meats are acid forming
highly acid forming
and the body likes an alkaline system
it doesn't want an acid system
and many a disease or most disease
is from an acid system
and since animal products like
meat
are highly acid forming
and some of the processed foods are
highly acid forming
like cheese for example is one of the
most acid-forming foods in the world
that you can eat
and therefore totally unfit for food
those create the basis and the
foundation for disease
so what are the foods that we should eat
that are alkaline forming fruits
vegetables
legumes
some nuts
others are
acid forming but slightly acid forming
now we also need acid-forming foods
because you need amino acids and they're
acids without them you can't build
protein
so some acid foods are required but the
preponderance should be alkaline foods
now what does it mean to have the
intelligent use of water
well most of your body consists of water
right
and we talked about the oceans in our
body the interstitial fluid
the plasma
and the intracellular
now once all the metabolites end up in
these fluids they have to be removed
from the body some are removed by the
kidneys some are removed by the sweat
glands
and others have to be discarded in other
ways some of them are ingested
macro they you get rid of them by
the intestinal system
through the skin or through the lungs
so how do we assist the body well
they're all dissolved in water right
correct so if you can flush your system
as one way of doing it so the first
thing you need to do
is you have to make sure you drink
enough water so that you do not only
have enough water to meet your needs
but also to flush the toxins out of the
system
so most people would say you need about
two liters of water a day
and if it's hot
and if you're working physically you
need more than that
so that assists the body to get rid of
it and what kind of water do you need
yes that's important yes
now nature supplies the best kind
rain water
artesian well water spring water
those are the finest forms of water that
you can have now water also has a
particular surface tension
and cells need another surface tension
so
there are surfactants that are added in
the blood proteins and other
lipid compounds to break down the
surface tension much like soap in water
breaks down the surface tension then you
can dissolve dirt easier
so it happens in the body
so good water spring water artesian well
water rain water
maybe i just want to also put in
when you're thirsty it's already too
late to drink then you should have drank
water already you should drink water on
a regular basis so most people
devise a little plan here or there one
way of doing it
is to
have a full glass of drinking water
in the restroom
so when you release water you replenish
it immediately that's a very good yes
system
and another way of using water
intelligently especially when you are
sick or the lungs are congested
then steaming
is
very very beneficial
in other words you put boiling water in
a bowl
you add a little bit of salt
that changes the the dynamics of the
steam
and put a towel over your head and
inhale the steam that loosens the phlegm
and helps the body to get rid of it you
know people take
substances that dry up the phlegm that's
exactly what you don't want to do
you want to get
rid of it because the body is telling
you i want to get rid of this stuff
so the mucous glands they they take
toxins and release them
and
your white blood cells get added to it
so
normal phlegm is white if you are
infectious then it's yellow
because there are white blood cells that
have died and given up those things that
they've taken up detoxifying the body
and now the body says
get rid of it don't
dry it out get rid of it
so steaming is very very beneficial
or sweat bars or steam baths
that's an intelligent use of water
fermentations
if you have a bronchial problem
then bring the blood to the lungs in
other words put hot fermentations with
water
that brings the blood to the surface
and helps to detoxify that particular
area okay but just for a practical
illustration
you say bring water to the to the chest
but is that in the form of a hot towel
that you put on there or correct now
heat is not enough it needs it needs to
have the steam the the water in it so
basically what you do is you can put a
dry towel
on top
of your chest
then you add a hot towel
with the
water steaming water on top of that so
that you do not burn put another dry
towel over that
put a plastic sheet over that go and lie
under wraps
and then change that three times and in
between
rub it down with ice water
whether that is quite
a procedure that's why many people don't
want to do it
but then you have a hot cold treatment
and you're also shunting the blood from
away from the skin to the skin away from
the skin to the skin
and this helps the body
to fight the problem
salt drops
are also something that you can do
hot and cold showers
and hot and cold rubs
these are all things that are very
beneficial so water is not only for
drinking it's for steaming it's for
fermentations
you can do
if you have an injury for example you
can put it into hot water and then into
ice water into hot water and into ice
water
uh
many many things can be resolved in in
that way there's also if you
if it's difficult to get into a bath
you can do one with where you have a
bucket with hot water you put your feet
in it
and you put a towel and that will also
get you sweaty correct
and then of course
herbs the natural
things that god has made available
and many many herbs have
very
good remedial qualities
so water treatment and simple herbs the
lord has taught us that great efficacy
for healing lies in the proper use of
water
these treatments should be given
skillfully
we have been instructed that in our
treatment of the sick we should discard
the use of drugs they are simple herbs
that can be used for the recovery of the
sick whose effects upon the system are
very different from that of those drugs
that poison the blood and endanger life
as we've discussed before prescribed
drugs are the number three cause of
death
as a consequence so it is well known
that that is the situation
and as we've also said previously people
take
a drug to solve a particular
ailment and then they have to take a
drug to
take care of the side effects which
again produces new side effects so they
take another one to to cope with those
add infinitum until they take a whole
handful
of pills and
burden the system
so pure water is for drinking it's for
steaming it's for inhaling it's for
sweat baths it's for fermentations
salt drops hot and cold showers etc
now
there was a scientist and his and his
name was
this one over here batman gildi but
apparently you pronounce it but
mangalesh
now he was an iranian doctor very
interesting fellow
and he had his training in the united
states of america
and after the revolution
he was
in iran and they locked him up
and he spent much of his time in jail
and being a medical doctor he was very
busy trying to help
all the inmates there
and
he didn't have any medication to give
them
and so he would prescribe water
if you have a headache drink a glass of
water if you have this element drink a
glass of water and many of them
actually got better right the ailment
went away
and so eventually he got so interested
that he divided them up into groups
and the one group got treated like they
regularly treat them in those facilities
and the other group was treated with
these water therapy
and the results were astounding
and he was busy with this experiment
apparently when
the notification came that he could be
released
and he said no no no i can't be released
now i'm busy with an experiment so
willingly stayed another six months in
jail
and
he wrote a book called your body's many
cries for water
and he was speaking about histamine
and water regulations now you know that
if you have an allergy you take an
antihistamine right
so he said allergens should be treated
with water for example asthma lung
dehydration
salt is also an antihistamine and you
should never take caffeine drinks you
must drink water instead of soft drinks
and juices
and
many in the world said well he is a bit
of a quack
so they didn't take him too seriously
but his results
speak for themselves
and his book the body's many cries for
water
became quite a bestseller
now it's interesting
that when somebody stumbles upon
something
he might have taken it too far and say
you know everything comes from water
well obviously not
allergens like for example asthma
can be alleviated by drinking a lot of
water
but they also come from other things
like casein for example in milk
so you can't take it too far but it's
interesting
that he recognized in that prison
that if you give water and people drink
more water then many an ailment can
disappear
so the the general
medical fraternity regards that as
quackery
but
the results speak for themselves
another thing that's very important in
the time that we are living in and that
we are heading for in particular
is charcoal
every household this is a sort of
uh purchase list right
make sure that your home chemistry
shop has your home chemist has all of
these things in good supply
and charcoal as i said is probably one
of the more important ones here's a
quote from the spirit of prophecy
i feel impressed to recommend
for your consideration the use of
charcoal
as a powerful agency for removing poison
from the system
i have on several occasions been
impressed to suggest the use of charcoal
and it has often brought relief when
every other means had failed some people
were on the verge of death
and charcoal turned it around it's
particularly if you have an infection or
just generally one of the ways to take
charcoal is to take charcoal tablets
or you could take a teaspoon of charcoal
water
or a juice if you don't like that that
gritty taste it's going to be gritty
anyway
and swallow it down
and it absorbs toxins it has these micro
pores
you know when we were doing uh lab
experiments then we would do hormone
analysis and often you have to send
trips you
get and get rid of whatever other
dissolved substances are present we
would use activate the charcoal
and then
centrifuge it down then you know that
the
soluble stuff has been removed and you
can work with whatever you have to it
works like a magnet for all that stuff
it's
amazing just while you're talking about
a magnet
you know the body is an electrical
system
and
we read that the life is in the blood
now in the previous lecture we discussed
that red blood cells generally have a
negative charge and they repel each
other
if you have an injury
or there's a medical problem those
charges are often reversed
which means that the blood is attracted
to it because it has a positive charge
now the blood also has stem cells in it
and the blood produced in the intestine
comes also from stem cells and some of
them are in a state of differentiation
they can become any kind of cell in your
body
so you have an injury
the blood is drawn to that
packs around it
and
starts working on that injury and
restores whatever needs to be restored
so if you need bone cells those stem
cells can provide the bone cells if you
need another cell they can provide that
so the life is in the blood there's no
doubt about it okay so that's where a
scab come from well yes that's the the
blood that has leaked through and it
makes a scab and it covers the affected
area and the skin regenerates underneath
so the blood is really the one that is
the life giver
so if you if you use charcoal how do you
do that well one of the things you can
do is you can make a poultice you can
just take a
linen cloth for example
and
cook up a little bit of linseed dissolve
some
charcoal in there spread it across
and then paste it on the affected area
and put some
what they call in america saran wrap
around it
or in our country we call it foil right
oh glad wrap blood wrap
and
then that will absorb any toxin in the
wound or in the affected area
but you can also make bigger ones and
place them over the liver
and draw out toxins particularly you
know people that have smoked
that nicotine will draw right into that
charcoal yeah and even if you uh
alcohol drinker alcohol any kind of
detox that you want to do a charcoal
poultice is an excellent way to go you
can also put it on the kidneys
absolutely any affected area and you
sleep with it
you can wrap the
wrap right around you
and go to sleep with it or walk with it
during the day and then discard it
because you don't want to have those
toxins go back into your body right
so you could take two or four capsules
of charcoal a day
charcoal is the preeminent detoxifier
and when taken on an empty stomach works
its way down into the intestines and
activates a blood pre-purification
process
known as interstitial dialysis
so it actually helps the body to draw
those toxins right out
so that is a very important item to have
in your first aid kit
so let's have a look at herbs and
naturopathy
are grateful to the invalids weary of
city life the glare of many lights and
the noise of the streets are the quiet
and freedom of the country
how eagerly do they turn to the scenes
of nature how glad would they be to sit
in the open air rejoice in the sunshine
and breathe the fragrance of tree and
flower
there are life-giving properties in the
balsam of the pine
in the fragrance of the cedar
in the fur
and other trees also have properties
that are health restoring
so here are a few simple
little guidelines we'll look at the
science in a moment
there's another tree she refers to again
take warm foot baths into which have
been put the leaves from the eucalyptus
tree
there's great virtue in these leaves and
if you will try this you will prove my
words to be true
the oil of the eucalyptus is especially
beneficial in cases of cough and pains
in chest and lungs
i want you to make a trial of this
remedy which is so simple in which costs
you
nothing
now it's interesting that a footpath is
often mentioned yes you know modern the
foot is the lowest part of the body
and the foot is the area
that accumulates most toxins
so a foot bath
you can even put a little bit of
charcoal powder into that footpath
will draw out those toxins and help your
body get rid of these things you know
that's actually true so if you have
a foot problem
most probably there's something not too
good in your body correct and for
example if you get septicemia
which is blood poisoning
and you get it in the foot
you have a very high chance of dying
because it's the lowest part of the body
and you have to get those toxins out of
your system
now your your feet
concentrate them now you can get them up
through the lymph but for that you have
to walk now people that have sore feet
don't walk
and that is a problem because the lymph
pumps are in your legs
they are your lymph pumps they pump the
lymph up and there are little valves
which prevent it from flowing back but
you have to get it up
until it goes back into the circulation
and go through
the whole process of cleansing it
so a foot bath is something that is
something that is worthwhile considering
so let's have a look at some
[Music]
publications this is the national
library of medicine
and it says pine needles contains
suraman
which has been reported to be effective
as an antioxidant
an anti-mutagenic
anti-tumor effect
and
not all pine needles are good we'll see
that in a moment but
generally
these are the publications that have
come out so again
pine needles have remedial substances
and one of them is
suraman
it says look at some others here's an
abstract we don't have to read at all
from this publication pine needles pinos
densiflora
have long been used as traditional
health promoting medicinal food in korea
to investigate the potential anti-cancer
effect
antioxidant
anti-mutagenic
anti-tumor activity
were assessed in vitro or in vivo pine
needles ethanol extracts significantly
inhibited iron induced lipid
peroxidation
and scavenged radicals in vitro so it's
very effective we don't have to read at
all
just to show that the science
backs the statement correct
so what's good about pine needle tea
pine needle tea has a pleasant taste and
smell that's a good start
it is rich in vitamin c five times the
concentration of vitamin c found in
lemons
can bring relief to conditions such as
heart disease varicose veins skin
complaints fatigue
boost the immune system of course
can help infections
it contains high levels of vitamin a
which is good for eyesight improves hair
skin regeneration etc it's an
expectorant for coughs to help relieve
chest congestion
it's also good for a sore throat they
say it brings mental clearness well if
your blood is improved
then your mental clarity will improve
you know we discussed in the last one
clumping
that reduces the oxygen supply yes
well if you do that and you cut your
oxygen supply by half that means your
brain is getting half of what it needs
right
one cup of coffee 40 40
reduction you don't want to do that you
want to have a healthy mind for a
healthy mind you must have healthy blood
yeah
can help with depression
that could be secondary as a result of a
better supply of oxygen to the brain
it's good for blood pressure so all of
these things
okay so pick some pine needles let them
soak in boiling water on yourself and
it'll add a crisp pine smell
all over the house
so here they say the eastern white pine
makes a great tea
but you should try and avoid cyprus and
yew trees as they have toxic needles
now there's something else that you find
in pine needles
besides suramin and that is shikimic
acid
or shikimate
there are toxic pine needles as we've
said be careful when drinking pine
needle tea drink the oil and the resin
that accumulates too
and this
shikimate or shikimic acid and their
derivacis they possess cancer-fighting
antiviral antimicrobial anticoagulant
and anti-thrombotic properties so they
help your blood to stay nice and thin
and
we were talking about
good blood right correct so the judicial
use of water
and
some of these simple remedies can be
used to keep the blood
thin
here's another scientific article news
medical life agency scientists are
anxiously searching for an effective
antiviral
to combat severe or critical covet 19
which has already caused over a million
deaths worldwide
a new study published in the
pre-print server bio rvix
reports the elucidation of the mechanism
of inhibition of sarskovi-2 by
non-nucleid inhibitor called suraman
so you find that in
pine needles right
now we do not have to talk about the
mechanism as to what is primary did it
come from outside or did it come from
inside
if you are aiding the disease then you
won't need to respond as vigorously to
the disease so in that way it will be
let's call it antiviral
ceramic also has been shown to be an
inhibitor against a wide variety of
other viruses
so basically what
the science shows
is that you reduce the output of these
substances if you think they come from
outside
and if you think they come from outside
the same applies it doesn't matter what
you think about it it can work it helps
correct
so
there are other herbs that you can use
and there are many web pages that talk
about these things try and find those
that use reputable sources
and don't just you know sprout whatever
they think
but basically if you go through all of
them there are some that they all have
in common they all suggest the following
oregano
oregano is a very popular herb in the
mint family that is known for its
impressive medical qualities
uh
it's plant compounds which include
carvacrol offer antiviral properties
so again let us put it this way
it
helps the body to rid the system of
whatever is ailing it and therefore we
do not have to have such a vigorous
disease response
and then that helps the body
the second one that is
recommended is sage
it's also a member of the mint family
it's an aromatic herb
and it also has antiviral properties
antimicrobial properties as well just a
question the use of these is it now in
food or is it making teas well you can
put it into the food as a as a condiment
or as herb
or you could
make a tea from
it basil
basil is
has many many redeeming qualities
and there are many types of basil some
of them are perennial
some of them are annual so make sure you
can plant them in your garden
and
some even have what they call holy
varieties
and one test tube study found that sweet
basil extracts including compounds like
epigenin and eusalic acid exhibited
potent effects against herpes virus
hepatitis b and enterovirus
so basically the bottom line is
there are substances
which help the body
to cope with whatever the problem is
now something like basil
as a as a very
interesting taste you can add it to your
food particularly italian type of food
loves basil
but once you get used to the taste of
basil
it's a wonderful herb just to place on
on an avocado sandwich for example
now i can eat a whole pile of it
and
once you get used to it then your palate
starts liking it and craving it
fennel is another one
that you should consider now remember
that all of these are alkaline forming
so in in that effect alone
they contribute to a healthy system
fennel has a licorice flavor
and they say it is potently antiviral
so again
if it can help your body
not to have to use all of these
mechanisms to get rid of whatever toxins
it is then that is a good thing
garlic
in a study in 23 adults with warts
caused by papilloma virus applying
garlic extract to the affected area
twice daily eliminated the warts
in all of them after one to two weeks
additionally older test tube studies
noted that garlic may have antiviral
activity against influenza a b
hiv hsv viral pneumonia rhinovirus says
which caused the common cold
now we did quite a few experiments
with garlic and also wild garlic we used
wild garlic as well and found it
it is incredibly antimicrobial it's in
fact better than some of the the
antibiotics
so
that's an interesting point
so these are substances that we can use
now you can make
certain drinks
that will be power bombs to help you in
a cold and flu situation and we'll talk
about them in a moment yeah and even if
you want to in the morning drink half a
clove of garlic with water
it's a very good
antibiotic
if you want to do that yes of course
some people will say it will interfere
with your romantic life
and some people can take it to excess
but
in times of disease
then
well
the romantic aspect fades into
into second place
lemon balm
lemon balm extract is a concentrated
source of potent essential oils and
plant compounds that have
anti-viral activity and they quote
many many scientific papers to back it
up
and test tube research has shown that it
has antiviral effects against avian
influenza
herpes
enterovirus and
many many things even in
children
peppermint is another plant that
one can effectively introduce into the
garden it also grows quite easily it has
antiviral co qualities
you can drink it in teas tinctures
and
you can have
natural oils from peppermint
put them into your steam baths to help
you
as an expectorant
they contain menthol and rosemarinic
acid
which have antiviral and
anti-inflammatory activity so you know
if you if you have
some of these herbs available you don't
have to have them all
but what is available
use it
rosemary is anti-microbial it's
anti-inflammatory it's an antioxidant
so you can add that to your food and you
can also use extracts and you can rub it
and put it onto fermentations to bring
that aroma out
so there are many many ways in which you
can use it it is excellent in cases of
influenza
hepatitis etc
echinacea is another one well everybody
knows about the
qualities of echinacea and echinacea tea
again it's very effective in viral
infections influenza
and
echinacea purpurea is thought to have
immune boosting effects as well making
it particularly useful for treating
viral infections so
the natural things that god has provided
not only helps you to rid you of the
toxins
but also supplies
the very compounds that you need to
boost your immune system because a lot
of infections like you mentioned earlier
most of these help with alkalinity
and a lot of infection inside of your
body comes from acidity correct
and what's also practical about these
that you've shown as anybody can grow
this
you can grow it in your in in a pot
outside on this on the porch
we have one patch in our garden where we
grow as many of these as we as we can so
rosemary sage basil all of those grow
readily in our garden
elderberry is for many people in case of
influenza the go-to
it's also known as sambucus so
it is made into a variety of products
elexas and pills and they treat viral
infections like flu and the common cold
for many many people this is the go-to
one
and it's very effective licorice
licorice tea
has many many uses and in chinese
medicine it's been used for centuries
and it contains all of these interesting
compounds
and they all have such interesting names
and these are the active substances and
they have powerful antiviral properties
also licorice helps with
blood pressure problems for example
test tube studies demonstrated
effective against
hiv rsv herpes virus and severe acute
respiratory syndrome related coronavirus
so this is one of the go-to's you can
make a tea of it i must say that's one
of my favorite do you like licorice tea
i also have licorice tea
when there is a
problem
astragalus
it's a flowering herb in traditional
chinese medicine
it boasts astragalus polysaccharide
which has significant immune enhancing
and antiviral qualities
ginger
we've planted quite a bit of ginger in
our garden and it's amazing one plant
gives you from one little tuber gives
you a huge
amount
and it's an alexa you can put it into
teas
many many natural remedies are
attributed to it it has been shown to
have impressive antiviral activity it
has high concentrations of potent
compounds
so this is another one of those that is
antiviral
anti-mutagenic
antimicrobial
and
if you put that together with echinacea
into a tea or you make a combination tea
excellent and you can maybe on the
practical side just on the pictures show
when it starts to grow that little
like a horn yes people can cut it off
and plant that part correct
related to it is ginseng which is also
used in the east particularly in korea
and it is very effective against viruses
by the way martin if you add ginseng or
ginger
to a garlic drink
then it masks
that potent aroma
that you get
and there are other advantages some say
that this one helps you
with your
vigor and gives you more energy etc and
then the the dandelion you know the
little cinderella of the flowering
plants
such a common little plan i just want to
say here most people think it's a weed
correct it says right here it's regarded
as a weed
but it has great medicinal pro
properties including antiviral and
it has
been shown to be very effective so some
of these edible flowers are excellent
you can make coffee of the roots of
dandelion correct you put it in foil and
roast it in the oven
correct
and then you get to some of the really
potent ones
and cayenne pepper cayenne is probably
a absolute must
in your little tool box
it contains natural
compounds called
capsicunoids
and that's what gives it its flavor and
it's anti-inflammatory
properties
it can reduce hypertension it can
prevent blood clots
it can prevent myocardial infarcts heart
attacks
so this is really a very very potent
uh
product to have in your house and it's
so simple to keep
so make sure you have this and if you
have circulatory problems
then drink some of this
and it it feels hot it feels like it's
burning but it's a sensation it's not an
actual burn yeah
so it doesn't create uh
the problems that an alkaloid like black
pepper for example would produce
so this is something that you can use so
if you have
problems heart problems palpitations or
anything of that nature
then put a teaspoon
of red pepper of cayenne
into a glass put it into
something like fruit juice or something
make it a little bit less potent
and then drink that down it can bring
almost
instant relief
and especially for
myocardial infarct they say that you
know a dose of
red pepper can actually assist the body
and you know that man that that spoke
about uh the bodies many cries for water
yeah
one of the things that you can do if
you're feeling faint is put a few
crystals of salt under the tongue
that is also a very effective way of
helping
to get your blood pressure restored
to what it should be so red pepper
or cayenne pepper has many many
qualities
and it is also anti-inflammatory
so it can help you with inflammation of
the body
of of any of of the urinary tract etc
turmeric is the other very important one
now we also grow turmeric in our garden
and we keep it frozen
and just take a little piece and put it
in the blender
so it contains curcumin
and that's the main component and it is
a potent anti-inflammatory it's probably
one of the most potent
natural anti-inflammatories that you can
get it's such a simple thing to have in
your house all right
now one of the things you can do with it
is
you can
make an
anti-inflammatory milk yes
so you take a plant-based milk
like soy milk or almond milk or any one
of those
and
the main component curcumin
dissolves in fat readily
now
these natural milks like almond milk or
soy milk contain
a high proportion of fat so that helps
but you can assist that even by adding
let's say a teaspoon of coconut oil
and then you add a teaspoon of
turmeric
in a half a liter of milk
and then bring it to a simmer
not boiling vigorously just bring it to
a simmer stop it
stir it
and then put it in a container cool it
down you can keep it in the refrigerator
and then use it like a medicine
three or four times a day
you take a few tablespoons of that or
you can
take a glass and drink it it doesn't
matter because it's not going to
to harm you in any way but it's one of
the most potent
anti-inflammatories
that you can find we even drink it
when it's still hot like a a hot drink
like a hot drink add a little bit of
honey that's it and uh enjoy and honey
is also anti-inflammatory correct i
don't think i even have honey in this
but honey is amazing for skin problems
for
burns for many many things you can use
honey
even with if you have very bad eye
infection
honey if you put it into the eye
is a very good but it's not very
pleasant
but it helps a lot with an infection in
the eye and the shelf life of honey
is almost infinite do you know martin
that they found honey
in
the tombs of pharaohs
that is still edible
yeah that's thousands of years old yes
that's thousands of years old so now if
you if you look at these compounds that
we've discussed so far
if you want to make a bomb yeah you've
now told us how to make golden milk gold
that's golden yes now tell us how to
make a bomb rocket fuel rocket fuel
cayenne pepper
so you take a teaspoon of cayenne
and you take
a few cloves of garlic
and a
sprig of ginger
and you blend that all together
and you add a little bit of honey if you
want to
and then you take that and turmeric and
turmeric and you put it all into that
blender and to make that rocket fuel
and then
you down it in one shot
and you feel the fire coming out of your
ears you can just see those those
those enemies being destroyed
and that is something that helps in
many many cases
i don't know if you mentioned
lemon ah yes we should put lemon on the
list as well with the skin
so wash the lemon well
take a slice and blend that in with your
rocket fuel
or generally speaking make yourself a
juice with
the whole lemon
and carrot and apple
and make a juice of that
and drink that as a booster high vitamin
a high vitamin c there's more vitamin c
in the skin plus all of the volatile
oils in the skin
all of those things
in that rocket fuel or in a juice
excellent
now stinging nettle is an amazing
amazing plant it's anti-inflammatory
it's anti-allergen it detoxifies
it is effective
for treating prostatic hyperplasia
that's enlarged prostate
but it's important to note that for that
you need the roots the roots are more
effective than the leaves both work but
the roots are just better so
to have a tea from stinging nettle roots
and blood sugar control and lowers blood
pressure
and it is a detoxifier part excellence
so if you have an ailment that involves
inflammation of any kind
that is probably one of the go-to teas
that you should have and it really helps
to cleanse the system
and then the simple nasturtium
what a powerful little plant
we planted a patch in our
in our greenhouse and it grows
magnificently you can use any kind the
the general one that is on the picture
here or the variegated one which has the
little streaks in it
it's potent potently antimicrobial and
anti-inflammatory
and you want to look at some of the
evidence
there are some scientific papers
anti-microbial and anti-inflammatory
activities of the volatile oil compounds
from tropolium marius the nasturtium
and it comes from the journal of
biotechnology
our studies have demonstrated the
efficiency of the natural compounds
of this plant
as an anti-inflammatory treatment in
animals the antimicrobial activity
proved to be selective depending on the
pathogens
there is the results are in agreement
with those of other studies our results
supported the selection and utilization
of these compounds
as antimicrobial agents in the treatment
of infections with microorganisms
resistant to existent antibiotics
so here's a very simple one
it has a sharp peppery taste you can eat
the flour
you can eat the leaves
so
when we have a problem we go into the
garden
and we take a leaf
or two
and chew it you can chop them up into
your salad and give it sort of a peppery
taste
you can eat the flour as ears just make
sure there's no bug in it
the bags like it too
if you get one of those stink bugs in
there i don't think it's going to be
that
great
but what's interesting for me is that it
says there
also with microorganism organisms
resistant to existing antibiotics it's
the same like garlic that is also
effective in that region
but this plant is amazing
so two or three times a day you go in
there and you pretend you're a grazer
and you eat a leaf and you eat
the flower and that is the same
as taking medication but it is not
harmful and doesn't have side effects
it's amazing amazing you see
if it's god's natural way it's always
the best correct
another
important one to have around is john's
wort
now particularly for
mental
problems and depression since john's
water is amazing
so
seasonal affective disorder that's
people that become depressed when it
becomes winter for example so it's a
mood lifter
without drugs you know you get mood
lifters that have other side effects
that you don't want now since john's
wort doesn't fall into that category
it supposedly helps with obsessive
compulsive disorder ocd
and social phobias basically it is an
anti-anxiety
product so it's a useful one to have in
your medicine chest
and then golden seal
goldenseal is a
medical
herb
it is praised for its antibacterial and
anti-inflammatory properties it is used
to treat skin disorders lack of appetite
heavy or painful periods sinus
infections in digestion
and other inflammatory or digestive
disorders it is considered a natural
antibiotic and is often combined with
echinacea
and promoted as
an item to strengthen the immune system
so it's a very potent one
you can of course get the tincture
then you take about 10 drops three times
a day
in a little bit of water
and
it is a very important product to add to
your medicine chest okay i have a
question again
these products that we've just seen
on how regular a basis
can you consume this
well the teas you can you can drink it
regularly throughout the day if you're
having the tinctures then they're more
potent than you use them about three
times a day
and most of the times
why i'm asking is because sometimes you
can buy this off a shelf and then that
will have
instructions on how many times but if
you plant it in your garden you're not
going to know
so maybe just read this is the beauty of
herbs the chances of you overdosing on a
herb or virtually no
scrupularia or figwort it's known to be
an antipyretic and anti-inflammatory
and it's used for laryngitis fever
swelling constipation and neuritis so
you see many of these have overlapping
effectiveness so you don't have to have
them all
but whatever's in your area try and get
that
but
ginkgo biloba is a very interesting one
and it's a very potent antioxidant
anti-inflammatory it improves
circulation heart health
and it's a blood thinner it improves
cognitive function and reduces anxiety
and
depression
so
it's something that you could use
together with
saint john's wort
for people that are depressed
so these are just
things that that can help people in this
modern society
this modern society is so depressed just
think of all the antidepressants that
people use that's the number one drug in
the world yes john's wort ginkgo biloba
now when i used to fly a lot
i used to get
flight thrombosis i had flight
thrombosis about three times from all
the flying that i did
so the lockdown was very good for me
but the
then i would i would make sure when i
fly that i take kinkobiloba yeah
and if i go on a long trip where i sit
i'll take kinkobiloba
is
an excellent product
you get it in a tablet form
and
well just take one or two tablets a day
away you go
eucalyptus we've already discussed it to
some extent and the oils
are
very potent they can be decongestants
disinfectants
anti-inflammatory
and tea tree oil falls into that same
category it's also anti-inflammatory
antibacterial anti-fungal
so martin if you do the steam inhaling
you can add a drop of eucalyptus oil and
a drop of tea tree oil it's very
disinfectant and together with the steam
it helps you to get rid of the problems
that have occurred in your lungs and
particularly
with these diseases that we have
today like the corona
it makes a very thick mucus
the steam loosens it
so this is the beauty of this way
you're not fighting the disease you're
helping the disease so your body is
throwing out whatever it is throwing out
whether it is an environmental toxin
or whatever you want to think that it is
your body is trying to get rid of it
so help the body get rid of it
and a little bit of banging on the back
together with the steam loosens the
flame
repeat it one or two times
you'll have coughing spells like crazy
if you put a little bit of eucalyptus or
or a drop just one drop is enough don't
put more because it'll overwhelm you
it'll if a little bit of clapping on the
back
helps to loosen it and if you have a
major coughing spell
that's part of your defense mechanism to
get rid of it yes so get it out it's
unfortunate but that's the way it is
that's the way don't depress it help the
disease don't fight the disease
lime blossom
lindenbuten
tea is amazing it relieves anxiety
it fights inflammation it relieves mild
pain it's a diuretic it lowers blood
pressure
helps with sleep disorder sues the
digestive tract
so here is a here is something that if
you are fighting disease this is an
excellent
tea because not only does it
fight the inflammation
it gives you that calmness so that you
can sleep yeah
and that's what the body needs it needs
rest
you know
people don't understand
that you have an anabolism
and you have a catabolism
the one builds up the other one breaks
down
now when you go into sleep mode you're
in catabolism
when you're in active mode you're in
anabolism
so when you are sick you want to help
your body to fight the disease and
therefore you don't want to divert
energy
into
waking activity yeah
rest sleep
do what the body tells you what it wants
so if i'm understanding correctly in the
catabolism
state you get rid of stuff that's why
you sleep so much when you're
sick correct yes
saw palmetto
here's another interesting one it
prevents hair loss mainly by converting
dehydro epi androsterone
the testosterone balance so it improves
urine effect that when i was younger
hair loss you might have solved your
problem with your hair
it helps for prostate hyperplasia
it regulates
testosterone levels and it's
anti-inflammatory
so sometimes you can combine things so
for example if you have prostate
problems
sore palmetto is
one that
will certainly assist in that but you
can combine it with others and i'll show
you some in a moment like buchu for
example we'll come to that
and it's anti-inflammatory
so saw palmetto is a very good one to
have
around
and if you combine it with something
like boohoo
has quite a pungent flavor
and it takes some getting used to
but it it's an excellent medicine it's a
disinfectant for the urinary tract
and it helps with bladder infections
cystitis
inflections of the urethra
the prostate kidney reduces hypertension
arthritis rheumatism it's really a
wonderful
wonderful plant now when we lived in the
cape
which has a winter rainfall it likes
cold temperatures and wet winters
it grew up in the mountains so we had a
regular
sauce these days we don't live there
anymore so we have to buy it in the form
of tea
it's an excellent one so
one of the the go-to's so this one you
combine
with saw palmetto yes
and
you can also use it as you say for all
urinary tract infections and it it is a
great cleanser
so any one of these combinations amazing
what can what you can do
there's also another one
chamomile flower
yes the chamomile i i think i didn't
even put it in here but chamomile yes
it's also calming yes very very good for
when you want to have a good night's
sleep sleeping disorders so
also mild pain it works for that as well
yeah so together with lime blossom tea
i'm sure that will be a good combination
another one that you can use for
sleeping disorders is passion flower
okay
the grenade flower passion flower so
passion flower tea chamomile
and lime blossom tea
if you add those three and you make a
concoction tea
then that is a sleep recipe
so these are the kinds of things you can
do
in a time where you will need a strong
immune boosting
system and by the way martin if you
if you have had these diseases and
you're debilitated or even if you're
vaccinated
and you feel that you have side effects
then help your body use charcoal take
the charcoal
and make sure you have the following
vitamins and minerals at hand these are
the ones that i would consider to be
on the top of the hit parade
in terms of what you need
selenium
magnesium
and zinc
those three
selenium and natural source in the plant
world
brazil nuts
are a very good source but you can buy
supplements
selenium supplement magnesium supplement
and zinc supplement those are
your immune boosting minerals you want
them in
your first aid kit
as for the vitamins make sure you have
your
vitamin b's if you want to have good
blood
vitamin b12
get the little soluble one that you put
under your tongue it's cheap
and it can help with with producing a
good blood
vitamin c they say particularly the
lipospheric vitamin c
which is in a liquid form you drink it
but
vitamin c in general
should be
in your first aid kit vitamin e of
course
vitamin a
folic acid
and vitamin d is absolutely essential
for a good immune system even in
countries
like southern africa where we live where
we have lots of sunlight i mean look at
yourself today your body is covered in
clothes you're not sitting outside
producing vitamin d
because a lot of our work is
indoors
nothing wrong with taking a vitamin d
supplement those are the main ones that
you should need for
a powerful immune response
and if you take all of those together
with charcoal
then you can alleviate many of the
unwanted symptoms
that are prevalent in the world today
maybe just important don't take it at
the same time as charcoal
a little bit because otherwise the
charcoal will absorb
correct yes there you must use your
common sense
charcoal is something that absorbs
everything so take that first
wait a few hours and then take your
supplements
and then another important thing martin
thousands die from neglect of human
kindness
love kindness
touch
there's an interesting story about this
hospital in india where they practice
these things during the crisis that the
world has experienced
where they gave personal touch natural
remedies lots of water
and
lots of kindness
and people were not nearly as sick as
those in the general
environment
where there was no contact whatsoever
social distancing
fear and all of these things
love kindness and touch
are some of the most important things
that you can think of and this is
something
that the world is lacking the love of
many will grow cold and now they've with
this whole scenario
that's the last thing
that
is
prescribed
the last thing and that's one of the
most distancing
i mean if you remember the previous one
we actually showed um gibraltar the
island of gibraltar and they are fully
vaccinated 100
but with their lock down no over the
season they said don't touch each other
don't hug
so i wonder how many old people died
because of lack of human kindness and
touch
in in the last year this is something
that
stands as a record against humanity
psalms 18 35
thou hast also given me the shield of
thy salvation and thy right hand is
holding me up
and thy gentleness
has made me great
one of the attributes of god is
gentleness
and the fruits of the spirit as we know
are love joy peace long suffering
gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance
against such there is no law
no law
but you know sometimes governments make
laws
against these things you know
unfortunately
the
reverser of everything what do you
always call it i call him the master of
reversal
then
it is natural that he will go against
what if god says love kindness touch
correct
and here is a letter in the spirit of
prophecy remember that human kindness
is not an unfailing spring but a spring
which must be supplied from the fountain
of life or it will run dry
you know the fact that god has been
removed out of society is responsible
for the lack of human kindness
just that interview that we spoke about
in austria
it is stunning how callous and cold
humanity has become
selfish selfish yes
so i want to end this little discussion
with psalms 91
because psalms 91 deals with the time of
trouble that we are
rapidly entering into
and it has such amazing promises
he that dwelleth in the secret place of
the most high shall abide under the
shadow of the almighty
i will say to the of the lord he is my
refuge and my fortress my god
in him will i trust
this is the first attribute
you have to learn to trust god
surely he shall deliver me from the
snare of the fowler and from the noisome
pestilence
he shall cover thee with his feathers
and under his wings shalt thou trust
his truth shall be thy shield and
buckler
and you shall not be afraid for the
terror by night nor the arrow that
flieth by day
nor for the pestilence that walketh in
darkness
nor for the destruction that wastes us
in noon day
it's interesting that the pestilence
walks in darkness right it's associated
with evil
i don't think we should go into that
otherwise we could get into trouble
again
but people should really start thinking
logically
and then this promise a thousand shall
fall at thy side and ten thousand at thy
right hand but it shall not come
nighty
so there are certain things that we can
do
to help us in a time such as this
and if we
make a little study of how to use
natural remedies
and apply these simple
means
together with human kindness and human
touch
you'll see what a difference it can make
especially in the time that we are
living in now
and we are going into and in a time when
this will be the only means left
to help people because the other will
have been
exhausted let's pray
heavenly father
you are
the author of life
you are the designer
you know what we need
you have
made choices available
out there in the plant world we can
choose that which is detrimental to us
and we can choose that which is
beneficial
and you have given us freedom of choice
help us to make right choices
to use the right plants
the right herbs
for
the needs of the body
in the time that we are living in
thank you for these tokens of your care
may we appreciate them
and use them in jesus name amen
[Music]
you